20 türkische rapmusiker 18 klubs ein
video eine botschaft zusammen
ich kann nicht schweigen hiervor
künstler scheinlich rief seine kollegen
zusammen jeder durfte sich ein thema
wählen der in berlin geborene fragen
direkt über umweltverschmutzung und
zerstörung der natur
die leute haben einfach die schnauze
voll und in dieser dieser dieses lied
ist einfach ein sprachrohr geworden so
hat sich zu einem sprachrohr entwickelt
was uns wirklich alle überrascht hat
suri hätte nie gedacht dass die leute so
eine reaktion zeigen wir sind einfach
sehr überglücklich über 20 millionen
klicks in sechs tagen ein video als
befreiungsschlag es geht um gewalt gegen
frauen jugendarbeitslosigkeit staatliche
unterdrückung junge türken sagen hier
was sie stört an ihrem land an ihrem
leben und obwohl der name des
präsidenten nie fällt ist doch klar
worum es geht
musik an jeden bewegen das video bringt
es auf den punkt was in unserem land
zurzeit abgeht das ist sehr mutig noch
wissen wir nicht welche folgen das haben
wird aber irgendwas wird sicher
passieren einige staatsmedien reagieren
wie gewohnt das propaganda blatt yeni
safak verleumdet die künstler als
terroristen akp politiker sprechen von
provokation und manipulation pacini als
kolumnistin der zeitung hürriyet fordert
von der regierung endlich gelassener zu
reagieren
lieder zu singen solange sie nicht zur
gewalt aufrufen sollte als freie
meinungsäußerung angesehen werden selbst
wenn die lieder die regierenden
kritisieren
in der türkei ist das schon lange keine
selbstverständlichkeit mehr
wenn sie nachts kommen und dich holen
lautet ein vers in zusammen findest du
keinen journalisten der darüber schreibt
sie sitzen alle im knast